انا اسمي نسمه يحيى عندي 23 سنه انا اول
عارضه ازياء القامه وتم اختياري من 50
سيده مصريه ملهمه بعام 2020
وعملت كتاب اسمه مجرم وانا صغيره في السن
ما كنتش بلاقي ولبس على مقاسي خالص في اي
حاجه
فكان الموضوع ده نوع من الاحباط ونوع من
المشاكل النفسيه اللي جوايا ان انا مش
قادره البس الحاجه اللي انا بحبها او حاجه
اللي انا عايزاها وبدات ان انا اي تصميم
بفكر فيه او اي حاجه حابه البسها واصممها
في دماغي كده على جواها وبعد كده بنزل
اشتري قماش بتاعها وببعته لحد ينفذه وبدات
في الموضوع ده وانا عندي حوالي مثلا 16
سنه كان الموضوع بالنسبه لي هو مشكله اكتر
وانا بدات احل المشكله
انا حضرتك المشكله
ليه ما يبقاش حل المشكله ده نجاحها وفي
نفس الوقت حاجه جديده ما كانتش موجوده قبل
كده
[موسيقى]
اغلب المجتمع مش بيتقبل الاستلام ان احنا
طول الوقت عندنا اي شخص مختلف عننا وبين
سبب
انا بالنسبه لي انا لو ما كانش عندي ثقه
بالنفس ما كانش هيشجعني ان انا اعمل اي
حاجه لكن اي حاجه كنت بقابلها سواء تنمر
سواء سواء حاجات بتضايقني انا كنت باخدها
من الجانب الايجابي في حياتي ان انا اخرج
دي مجرد سلم انا بطلع عليه عشان خاطر اوصل
لحاجه انا حباها
دايما معروف عنه عرجات الازياء بيكون لهم
طول معين وزن معين ملامح معينه وانا حبيت
ان انا اكسر النمط ده عشان خاطر نبعد على
عنصريه او اختلاف تماما ان زي ما الناس
الطويله بتقدر تعمل بث برضو الناس القصيره
ممكن ان هي تقدر تعمل
للاسف خلينا نقول ان المحلات مش بيتوقف
فيها القمر فبالتالي هم بيصدقوا ان هم
يشتروا لبس الاطفال
فبالتالي ديزاين الاطفال مش بيكون مناسب
مع السن بتاعهم فبيبدا الناس يتعاملوا
معاهم بشكل كوميدي او بشكل ساخن لان
متفقين ان اللبس بتاعنا هو بيدينا ثقه من
نفسه
اي حد في الدنيا بيتعرض لنظرات سلبيه طويل
قصير رفيع كلنا بلا استثناء بنتعرض
الموضوع ده
ازاي ان انا اقدر احب نفسي فعلا واقدر
اتقبل منها وقتها انا مش هيهمني المجتمع
[موسيقى]